let's go to back to the six one seven
area code different possible local
caller caller from six one seven what is
your name where are you calling from and
what's on your mind today um hi David
it's me teri I'm can you hear me we can
hear you fine teri go ahead you hear me
hello oh okay good just wanted to make
sure um I just wanted to call about the
Jane Sanders investigation right because
uh it looks like the feds are trying to
look into her conduct over the way she
operated the Burlington College with
regards to the specific loan and all
that and I know a lot of progressives
have been ah saying that this is somehow
a political witch-hunt and all that -
and I think that it's not going to go
anywhere but I'm not a little bit
worried because the way that she did the
loan application is a little bit fishy I
just want to know what do you kind of
think I believe that it is not going to
go anywhere I it's been revealed that
the entire Jane Sanders thing is
effectively premise taun hearsay and
that it appears to be sort of a
deliberate attempt to just say hey
everybody is under investigation
everybody's equally wrapped up in all
sorts of sketchy stuff I think that if
there's anything there from from
everything I know right now I believe
that it is sort of like a administrative
or bureaucratic questions if anything
and I don't think it's going to go
anywhere but you know what I'm not
ideologically committed to anything and
if I if I hear or if I see other
evidence teri
then I'll revise my thoughts on it but I
think it's going nowhere okay got it
yeah thanks all right no problem at all
and on that note we will wrap up calls
for this week thanks to everybody who
called very very much appreciated and on
that note we will go to a break we will
take calls again that I promise you
folks believe me